so from roughly two thousand five to
when you were sitting at your desk to
now 2013 there was no point when you
wanted to abandon project like even as
top of the god financing going away
three times there was no time when you
said you know what maybe this is not for
me well not that I can remember but that
doesn't mean that that didn't happen you
know I had I'd been writing my entire
life so in different capacities whether
it was you know shorts or short films or
you know novels or whatnot so killing
Winston Jones believe it or not was my
first headfirst dive into features and I
don't recall ever wanting to quit only
because I hadn't really even started at
that point I hadn't finished a feature
and I wanted to finish a feature so that
probably gave me a little bit more
incentive and a little bit more Dr to
keep pushing forward with it and having
read so many different pieces of
material innovative I knew that I could
potentially write a feature and I just
wanted to see what that process was
about so my writing process is a little
bit slower I spend you know anywhere
from three to six months developing
characters and character arcs and
storylines I have a big picture of the
entire story before I even write a piece
of dialogue I'll be thinking about
dialogue for specific characters and
I'll write them down here and there but
I don't start writing dialogue in the
entire story until I feel like the
outline and the arcs and the story is
bulletproof so you know it was it was
such an interesting process for killing
with some Jones because I had to learn
what it was to board you know I had to
learn what it was to dissect characters
and make them have different voices and
to have arcs you know and I had to learn
what it was to make sure that every
single scene had conflict or there was
an emotional shift in your characters
whether it was your protagonist or
antagonist all the pieces that have
come together I had to learn that along
the way so I think that's probably why
this particular project was a little bit
longer than my other ones but you know
like I mentioned before I mean I think
most of the time if someone comes to me
and says that they wrote a script in
three weeks and it just flew out of them
and it was so amazing and it was
enlightening I just don't believe that
because I don't know that that's
possible I think that it takes time and
it takes effort and it's a slow process
sometimes if it needs to be and you
can't force creativity so you know I I
my last script I came up with the
concept of it I thought about the
concept for probably a couple years and
then finally when I decided to sit down
and make it my next project I probably
spent about three months developing the
characters in the story lines and and
then probably another six months six to
nine months writing it so and we'll see
I finished writing my next project in
sandy please about a year and a half ago
and we are hopefully going into
production early next year and if we go
into production early next year you know
best-case scenario will be in film
festivals by the end of the year or in
theaters the following year so that's
still a aunts a 34 year process and I
think that that's part of filmmaking
it's part of the business it just it's a
process it takes time
you